- [Instructor] Where we
left off in the last video,
we had seen what would
eventually be called
The First Crusades,
and it was, from a European point of view,
seemed successful.
They were able to take
back much of the Holy Land
from Muslim rule.
The Byzantine Empire was able to take back
a significant chunk of
the Anatolian Peninsula
from the Seljuk Turks,
who were also Muslim,
and over the next few decades,
this European rule over the Holy Land
only gets consolidated.
This is a zoomed in version
of what it looked like,
and you can see these Crusader states
that were set up, or
these Crusader kingdoms,
and, as I pointed out in the last video,
even though the Crusades
were apparently to help
the Byzantines reclaim
land, as you can see,
when the Crusaders took the Holy Land,
they, for the most part,
kept it for themselves
and sat up these kingdoms.
So, we are about here.
We are about here on our timeline.
Now, as we fast forward
a little over a decade,
as we get to the middle
of the 12th century,
you do have the Muslims
being able to take back
some of the territory.
In particular, Edessa and Aleppo,
and so this spawns what
will eventually be known
as the Second Crusade,
and it's really the second
of many crusades.
Now, these are what historians
consider the official
numbered crusades, but there
were many other crusades
in this time period, in roughly
this 200 year time period
during the High Middle Ages.
You had crusades against
Germanic non-Christians
in Northern Europe.
You had crusades in Spain
in order to retake land
from the Muslims, which they
had for several hundred years,
what's known as the Reconquista.
So, after Aleppo and Edessa were taken,
you have the Second
Crusades, which end up being
quite unsuccessful, and
it really doesn't change
what the Middle East looks like,
but then, as you get to
the end of the 12 century,
you have a significant event.
In 1187, you have the Sultan Salah ad-Din,
often known as Saladin, being
able to retake Jerusalem
and much of the Holy Land.
Remember, this is after
roughly 90 years of rule
of Jerusalem by the Western Europeans,
by these Crusader kingdoms,
so this really strikes
a chord with the west,
and so they decide to
launch what will be known
as the Third Crusade.
The Third Crusade does make some gains.
In fact, this is a crusade
that gets significant buy-in
from the king of Western Europe.
Philip the Second of France gets involved.
The English king, Richard the First,
or Richard the Lionheart, gets involved.
The Holy Roman Emperor Fredrick
Barbarossa gets involved.
When I say Holy Roman
Emperor and the empire,
you should really think
of medieval Germany.
Now, as they go there,
Fredrick Barbarossa, he drowns in a river.
This is very dispiriting for his soldiers,
so many of them turn around,
but Philip the Second
and Richard the Lionheart
are able to engage with Salah ad-Din,
and they are able to gain some land.
In particular, the region around Acre,
and they're able to get some
concessions from Salah ad-Din
for unarmed Christian pilgrims
to visit the Holy Land,
especially Jerusalem.
Now, Salah ad-Din dies
as we approach the end
of the 12 century, so in the
beginning of the 13th century,
the Fourth Crusades get launched,
and these are interesting
because the Crusaders,
with the help of Venetian traders,
they actually engage with
the claimant to the throne
of the Byzantine Empire,
with the hope that
if they can help them
come back to the throne,
then they can provide them
the necessary resources
in order to continue on with the Crusades.
Well, they are able to put
the claimant on the throne,
but then an uprising takes that claimant
down from the throne,
and so the Crusaders
don't get their payment,
but they want that payment badly,
and so, they decide to take
Constantinople themselves,
and as we mention in other videos,
this is really the dagger in the heart
between the relationship
between the East and the West.
We already talked about
the Great Schism of 1054,
but now, you have the
West, who are followers
of the Latin Church, which
eventually gets known
as the Roman Catholic Church.
They are sacking Constantinople,
the capital of the Byzantine,
or the Eastern Roman Empire,
the most important city
in Eastern Christiandom,
and once they successfully sack
the city in bloody fashion,
they break up the Byzantine
Empire amongst themselves,
and you can see how they break it up.
So, the Fourth Crusade
had very little effect
on the actual Holy Land,
but it does cause a temporary
end to the Byzantine Empire.
As we get to 1261,
Constantinople is retaken
by the Byzantines,
but once again, this is
the beginning of the end
of the Byzantine Empire.
The fact that for half a century,
it was taken over by the West,
so you can imagine, with
Jerusalem still in the hands
of the Muslims, many in
the West are not satisfied,
and in 1212, an interesting
event may have occurred.
There are some accounts of what is known
as a Children's Crusade.
The stories of the Children Crusade are
that a child, and there's
different accounts as to
exactly the story, but
something to the effect
that Jesus has told them to
go with other pure children
to the Holy Land and convert
the Muslims to Christianity,
and so then, they go on this march,
and there's tens of thousands of children,
but they don't make it to the Holy Land.
They either die of starvation
or they get sold into slavery on the way.
Historians today aren't sure
whether it really happened
as that account implies.
That's why I put these question marks
next to the Children's Crusade,
but regardless of the actual facts here,
as we go into the first
quarter of the 13th century,
Jerusalem remains in the
hands of the Muslims.
A Fifth Crusade is launched
to retake Jerusalem,
which is a failure.
Eventually, a Sixth Crusade is launched,
and this is reasonably
successful at retaking
some land in the Holy Land,
but shortly thereafter, you
have a non-numbered crusade,
the Barrens Crusade, that
rivals the First Crusade
in its success in taking territory,
and so you can see,
after the Barrens Crusade
right over here, they're able to take back
a good amount of territory,
but then, in 1244, Jerusalem
is retaken by the Muslims,
and then you have the Seventh and Eighth
and Ninth Crusades afterwards,
and you have these other efforts
that are sometimes called Crusades,
but for the most part,
these are unsuccessful,
and as we get into the end of the 13th
and early 14th centuries,
the Holy Land falls back
under Muslim control.
This is a map of the region
as we enter into the 14th century,
and you can see that
the Muslims have retaken
not just the Holy Land, but
most of the Anatolian Peninsula,
with only Constantinople being
in control of the Byzantines,
and that lasts until 1453, when the Turks
finally take Constantinople as well.
When you look at the map at
the beginning of this video
and look at the map here,
you can see that the Crusades
weren't really successful
at changing the picture
in the Holy Land.
There were areas where the
Crusades were successful,
or that Crusader mentality was successful.
You can see that, now that
we're in the 14th century,
much of the Iberian
Peninsula has been taken
by Christian kingdoms from the Muslims.
The Muslims, at this period,
are left with only Grenada,
so the Reconquista, to some
degree, was successful,
and it's going to continue until 1492,
when the last Muslims
are expelled from Spain.
Now, one thing that I felt
when I study the Crusades
is it's very confusing how
Jerusalem in particular
goes back and forth
between different parties,
and just to get an overview
of what actually happened,
this timeline might be helpful.
Green shows Jerusalem
under Muslim control.
Red shows it under Christian control,
so at the end of the First
Crusades, it switches hands.
The Christians are in control all the way
until Salah ad-Din takes it back.
Now, the Muslims are
in control all the way
until you get to the Sixth Crusade,
where they're able to
take some territory back
and even parts of Jerusalem,
and especially in the Barrens Crusades,
they're able to take
significant territory back,
but in 1244, Jerusalem is
retaken again by the Muslims.